it is my honor to introduce our speaker
John walk from the natural resource
defense counsel or NR t see at NRDC john
is a senior attorney and also director
of the organization's clean air program
John has actually been at NRDC since the
year 2000 and has been leading up the
organization's clean air advocacy effort
ever since then so as a significant
decade of experience in this area for
NRDC in his position John works on most
of the major provisions of the Clean Air
he works on the title one program which
is the new source review as well as
state implementation programs he works
on the air toxics program other type 3
the acid rain program under title for
and the operating permits program under
title 5 prior to joining NRDC John also
had a distinguished experience at US EPA
he worked there from nineteen ninety
seven to two thousand in the opposite
Joe general counsel and particularly
hair and radiation well office worked
again on a variety of different pieces
of the Clean Air Act but in particular
was the primary Ernie responsible for
the title five operating permit program
so job comes to us with just a wealth of
experience under the Clean Air Act and
significant knowledge about the various
issues in this arena john is a graduate
of Duke University where he has a
bachelor's degree he also went to
Harvard Law School and I just want to
sort of give a I guess a personal
account as well John is some of you know
I used to work at NRDC I was in Chicago
John is in the DC office and so today is
actually the first time that I've had
the opportunity to to meet John in
person but i will say that during my
time at NRDC I certainly had heard of
John walk he's someone who is very well
known within an organization of roughly
400 environmental advocates who are in
so passionate individuals everyone's
working really hard to protect the
environment but there are certain people
who are known as this sort of some of
the stars in the organization and John
is certainly one of those people he's
been an incredible advocate at NRDC as I
said her
more than a decade he's leading some of
the organization's most of the advocacy
efforts and we're looking forward to you
giving us your presentation today I
wanted to thank Yale and everyone here
for the invitation and the honor of
coming to speak here it's the first time
I've actually spoken at the law school
and I was a real pleasure I told Bruce
that I do try to minimize the
out-of-town speaking engagements I do
because I have three young children 85
and three in a six month old puppy who
is the fourth child and a wife who's a
partner at a law firm and a litigator
who's on a six-month travel stint right
now for the close of discovery in a case
that's ending and where the discovery
period closes in mid-november so this is
my one out of town trip for the rest of
2012 and it was an honor to to come
visit all of you here so thank you again
for the invitation like like any good
environmentalist heroic image of himself
or herself I want to start speaking in
enthusiastic defiance of the conventions
and rules for this lecture which are to
address climate change without talking
about climate change I cannot do that I
shall not do that and as the line from
one of Samuel Beckett's novels instructs
us you must go on I can't go on I will
go on the name of that novel
coincidentally was the unnameable seemed
kind of appropriate for today's lecture
series and i have found in the past when
speaking on environmental topics that
it's quite suiting it's quite a suitable
fitting to try to quote an absurdist or
an existentialist at least once because
it always seems to fit the occasion and
no more appropriately than when
discussing the topic of climate change
which seems to defy not just easy
solutions but any solutions at least
those that are acceptable in the
political realm of Washington DC where I
where I practice and
conduct my advocacy now lest you think
that environmental attorneys in
Washington or anywhere for that matter
sit around quoting Samuel Beckett let's
get down to the real world the real
dysfunctional dystopian partisan
pandering cynical world of politics in
Washington DC which is the the petri
dish in which all of these experiments
for progress to combat climate change
play out and more frequently do not play
out because of the the politics that is
the currency of that town and that is
really indistinguishable from the
attempts to enforce or create law and
policy in our country the the organizing
principle for my talk is going to be the
the organization in two to three
categories of advocacy that the
environmental community has settled on
by and large to try to make progress
notwithstanding the considerable
political challenges and obstacles that
we face I'm going to just briefly
mention the categories so you'll know
where I'm going and I'm going to spend
some time with with examples and
anecdotes within each category but I do
want to say at the outset that I hope
that after this initial period the
conversation can become the you know
today's talk can become a conversation a
dialogue I'm I'm eager to hear your own
thoughts and questions about this topic
which is an incredibly interesting one
it's one I I live and breathe every day
in the trenches of what seems like a
constant guerrilla warfare and so I i
trust that some of your questions would
trigger thoughts on on my part that are
kind of ingrained that are not part of
my prepared remarks and i'd like to to
draw those out to the extent possible
with your cooperation so i invite you to
ask questions while I'm speaking and
certainly towards the latter half I hope
we can have a robust Q&A session so the
kind of the metis strategy which isn't
terribly sophisticated insightful but is
one that the environmental community
kind of stumbles into with many of our
battles is what you might call in a
waggish way and all of the above
strategy riffing off of the Republicans
insistence on an all-of-the-above energy
strategy which means continuing
subsidies for coal nuclear and oil by
and large but the all-of-the-above
strategy through environmental community
is simply to look for opportunities for
progress wherever they may exist and to
create them where to create
opportunities where they don't currently
exist during the bush years we resorted
to advocacy conducted very frequently at
the state level because we didn't
control the White House or at least
environmentally minded politicians we're
not occupying the White House and you
know the the Congress wasn't a terribly
welcoming place either so a lot of the
progress was made in california which
serves as a driver there's an
institutionalized role in the Clean Air
Act for California to set progress
especially in the realm of vehicles that
other states can then follow so we
devoted a lot of our efforts there in
Washington we resorted to what we call
the outside game when you have a hostile
administration you resort to the outside
game litigation communications public
education and awareness controversy you
know things that are going to try to
garner attention around the issues that
drive our advocacy in the energy
environment and public health space with
an administration coming in that by its
campaign positions and appointments and
early speeches at the beginning of the
Obama administration was was was more
open to environmental progress reversing
some of the policies of the Bush
administration nowhere more prominent
really prominently really then climate
change in and in some key respects that
can touch pun as I go on it's more of an
inside game strategy you have an
administration that will actually be
responsive to the comments that you file
on rulemaking proposals pursuant to the
Administrative Procedure Act there's
more of an openness to enforcing the law
and not you know defying the law and
running the clock through the entire
eight years of an administration only to
be overturned in court as we saw with
the Bush administration for example with
the Massachusetts versus EPA case that
went up to the Supreme Court with
several conventional Clean Air Act cases
that I worked on that I work on still
where there were reversals by the US
Court of Appeals in the DC Circuit so
you you adapt to the circumstances and
the political circumstances are foreign
way one of the biggest drivers for how
we conduct our advocacy whether it's a
litigation strategy administrative
interactions communications strategy and
state-level advocacy just to name a few
that said the categories that I'm going
to organize for discussion today concern
how we have decided to try to continue
to make progress in combating climate
change and reducing carbon pollution and
the other greenhouse gases that
contribute to man-made climate change
the first in defiance of today's lecture
top title is the direct regulation of
carbon pollution under the Clean Air Act
the spinoff from the authority
recognized by the Supreme Court in the
Massachusetts versus EPA decision the
second category is the achievement of
carbon pollution reductions as a co
benefit of reducing other forms of
pollution under the Clean Air Act so for
example if you are enforcing a clean air
program whose primary objective
is to reduce smog pollution soot
pollution mercury and other toxic air
pollution when that is carried out very
often you have collateral benefits or Co
benefits from the compliance decisions
or the business decisions made by the
businesses that are regulated pursuant
to those let's call them conventional
air pollution programs smog sit and
toxics for shorthand okay that is where
I spend most of my time and effort as
the clean air director my responsibility
with a single other staff attorney in
Washington is to ensure the enforcement
of the Clean Air Act protection of the
Clean Air Act and good policy in the
realm of those conventional air
pollutants but I work extremely closely
with our climate Center which is a part
of our climate and air program writ
large with the responsibilities for
those few attorneys and other staff
working more directly on on climate
change issues the third category I'll
just call you know miscellaneous or
other it is a combination of strategies
focused on the states focused on more
creative applications of federal law for
example through the common law which
have effectively failed but which
produce some notable benefits that are
worth discussing as well and then kind
of the grab bag of energy efficiency
renewables smart metering Public Utility
Commission reforms a whole grab bag of
activities where through structural
changes and improvements and better
policy that promotes energy and energy
efficiency qua energy efficiency you can
achieve carbon benefits because the
plant that's becoming more efficient a
power plant that's become more efficient
is going to have you know marginal
improvements and its carbon profile as
well by virtue of the fuel it burns and
and its efficiency levels and other
factors so those are the those are the
three categories now i should say since
i had mapped these categories out in my
mind before coming here as i was sitting
over in the offices with josh i actually
found an article from The Wall Street
Journal which I usually try to avoid
reading at least the editorial page and
it's october eight should there be a
price on carbon i thought how
appropriate i'm at yale and we're
discussing should there be a price on
carbon and the wall street journal as
you might imagine the editorial board at
least certainly thinks there should not
be but they had three different
individuals that they were asking about
three three approaches to reducing
carbon dioxide emissions which is a
little text box here that the Wall
Street Journal has helpfully included
force and so I looked at those ants like
oh that's interesting how the journal
began to reduce carbon emissions first
cap and trade a second carbon tax and
third subsidies now let me tell you that
those three organizational principles
are nowhere close to the organizational
principles that we follow or the
categories for my remarks and why is
that well first of all it's the wall
street journal writing this this is a
this is almost an exercise in you know
kind of self-defeating solutions because
of course cap-and-trade right
practically originated at Yale the the
foundation of the 1990 clean air act
amendments acid rain program which was
an a cap-and-trade program for sulfur
dioxide it was it was enthusiastically
supported by the first Bush White House
market-based environmentalism has been a
mantra of the Republican Party for for
quite a while throughout certainly
throughout the 90s heading into the
2000s and then all of a sudden
cap-and-trade became the demonized
slogan on posters by the Tea Party in
august of two thousand right before the
election now who would have thought
that tea party activists even knew what
cap and trade was in a way to become so
sufficiently enraged by it that it
consumed these town hall meetings along
with Obamacare attacks in the month of
August when Congress was on recess after
the passage of the house climate
legislation waxman-markey and before the
midterm elections in many ways you can
point to the failure of the Senate
climate bill to that month in August and
the failure of the climate advocates
writ large to respond sufficiently to
this kind of budding political movement
and attack that had seized upon
cap-and-trade of all things the kind of
the intellectual principle that had
guided Republican opposition to command
and control environmentalism for nearly
a decade well what was going on and
what's going on with the appearance in
this box here cap and trade has become
in Washington and in today's political
conversation a ver boton term it's a it
can't you know it's the name that dare
not speak itself and that is because
starting in August of that month
probably sometime before them but really
crystallized in August onward it became
synonymous with carbon regulation it
became the rights kind of code word for
addressing man-made climate change and
by and large and policy and legal and
political circles in Washington today
that has continued to be true so the
Wall Street Journal highlighting this is
a very cynical way of saying oh there
they go again anything that has to do
with reducing carbon is just a return to
failed cap-and-trade legislation that
couldn't even get through a Democratic
Senate got through the house could not
get through a Democratic Senate okay so
this is the this is kind of the wall
street journal on the right and and and
and you know kind of baiting people to
try that again and you will notice in
the discourse surrounding any EPA
regulation of carbon pollution at least
from a so-called stationary sources
industrial sore
as opposed to the vehicles they will
return to that charge of cap-and-trade
again and again as an indictment in an
allegation second carbon tax is one my
favorites how many politicians have been
reelected in your memory running
affirmatively on a tax platform I'm
going to raise your taxes okay this is
another kind of baiting invitation that
the only way you can put a price on
carbon well rather step back even one
step further the only way you can reduce
carbon emissions at all is through a
carbon tax and you know to to I know two
of the three people in this in this
article responding to this question they
kind of dutifully walk through the
academic arguments and the intellectual
arguments for why it makes sense to put
a price on carbon through a carbon tax
I'd like these well-intentioned
individuals to come with me on any one
of the dozens of Lobby visits that I do
in Washington on a monthly basis and try
to sell this to a 26 year old staffer
who knows that if they take a memo to
their boss saying that he or she should
support a carbon tax they're going to be
laughed out of the room they want to
make it that far they won't get past the
LD or the LA the legislative director or
the legislative assistant so again not a
viable political solution in Washington
last one subsidies subsidies seriously I
mean they're they're arguing for further
so this is the Wall Street Journal
arguing for subsidies as a solution to a
problem that they don't think exists so
you'll not be surprised I hope you'll be
I hope you will expect that these are
not the strategies that we are pursuing
I mean that then the you know that these
this is not how we are organizing
advocacy that we think will be effective
in the real world because at the end of
the day that's the metric that drives us
we're really going to make progress in
the real world not can we have a more
sophisticated you know intellectual
conversations on the pages of a given
newspaper but are we going to drive
better solutions and policies so let's
let's jump in direct regulation of
carbon pollution under the Clean Air Act
I trust that this informed audience
knows that the Obama administration has
successfully issued vehicle co2
standards both fuel economy standards
from the department transportation and
actual carbon pollution standards under
the authority of the Clean Air Act for
vehicles on the industrial front or the
stationary source front using the
parlance of the Clean Air Act the
administration has proposed performance
standards just for new source power
plants in other words you know brand
spanking new power plants those yet to
be constructed there's a transition
period for those that are in the process
of being permitted in construction
constructed but that's as far as they've
been willing to go and they've only been
willing to issue a proposal and they've
only been willing to do it essentially
under duress as a result of a lawsuit
filed by NRDC you Sierra Club
Environmental Defense Fund and some
other groups this is part of our
strategy leading up to the Massachusetts
vs. EPA case which was effectively a
case about vehicles in carbon pollution
we had mounted parallel demands that the
administration used the authority of the
clean air act to reduce carbon pollution
from industrial facility specifically
power plants which are far and away the
biggest sources of industrial carbon
pollution in the United States oil
refineries or a distant second and of
course the Bush administration had
rebuffed those demands and requests but
after the the Supreme Court decision in
Massachusetts versus EPA which affirmed
that co2 is an air pollutant under the
Clean Air Act the writing was on the
wall since there were you know not
terribly demanding factual findings that
the administration or that the EPA would
have to make to designate to indicate
whether co2 was the type of pollution
that caused harm
either to health or the environment and
a manager sufficient to trigger the
regulatory measures of the Clean Air Act
so we knew that you know once we won the
Massachusetts versus EPA case it was
just a matter of time so you know as a
litigator you're thinking years and
years in advance to overcome a hostile
administration about how you set up the
chessboard so that when you get a
friendlier administration that you've
got the legal you've got a Supreme Court
decision you've got the you know the
kind of the the tolling of the time
period for the agency to consider your
request to deny your request you have
finally j'en see action I mean these are
all kind of administrative law buzz
words but this is what you have to do in
order to set things up years and years
in advance okay so even this
administration though taking the baby
step of proposing new source power plant
standards for co2 has been altogether
unwilling to take additional steps to
regulate existing source power plants
which as we all know or the ones putting
out co2 plans that haven't been built
yet aren't doing that yet and wall
street and market conditions and the
price of natural gas aren't setting up a
lot of new coal-fired power plants to be
built anyway it doesn't make sense it's
not economical so the mark is not even
going there so these standards will be
important when the new source standards
are adopted we we we know after the
election we hope soon after the election
by the end of the year we don't know
existing source power plants though
however following a you know a political
dance the head of EPA the EPA
Administrator Lisa Jackson announced
that she has no plans to regulate co2
from existing power plants I think those
were her words no plans so as a party to
the settlement agreement we have been in
discussions with the administration that
I am not at liberty to discuss but there
has been no change in that public
posture about the administration having
no plans we are going to continue to
press and at the end of the day if it
comes to it we have the ability
to resume the lawsuit that resulted in
the settlement agreement for all the
legal mavens in the audience one
distinction and a tool that we don't
have at our disposal EPA is not under a
consent decree with the environmental
plaintiffs to issue performance
standards for power plants co2
performance standards they are under a
settlement agreement the difference
between those two is whether the agency
is that the consent the terms of the
agreement can be enforced in court with
the penalty for the administrator being
contempt that is the case with a consent
decree that is not the case with a
settlement agreement the Justice
Department will not enter into a
settlement in which an agency is bound
by judicial order and contempt
possibility of contempt if there is not
a mandatory statutory duty okay that is
the case very frequently with deadlines
statutory deadlines and so you will see
consent decrees entered much more with
deadlines case deadline suits it's not
the case here so the remedy for refusal
to carry out the terms of a settlement
agreement and by the way the
administration was supposedly bound by
the settlement agreement to propose
these standards for existing sources
back in i believe February they miss
that deadline our remedy would be to
resume the original lawsuit brought
against the Bush administration for
refusing to issue these standards even
before Massachusetts versus EPA was
decided that's a multi-year process so
as a balance as an advocate as an
attorney now do you try to continue
negotiate and talk to you if you know
things fall down you know things fall
apart completely you have this
opportunity but it's a process that
could drag things on so we've you know
as you can tell me at our calculation
for now that patients and and continuing
to at least talk with the administration
or or the right course
now there is Authority under the Clean
Air Act to address co2 pollution from
existing sources it's in section 111 d D
is in David of the Clean Air Act and it
essentially confers upon States through
through procedures and plans that are
similar to state implementation plans
other than or the Clean Air Act for
these overarching kind of road maps for
reducing all forms of conventional
pollution until you meet your health
goals there's something quite similar to
that under the Clean Air Act that EPA
has said would be available for for
carbon pollution and a lot of academic
writing about it there was a recent
conference at the Nicholas school at
Duke just sponsored on this topic and so
we've been doing our own thinking and
about you know how you would design such
a system one idea that we've mentioned
publicly as a preview to a paper that we
plan to release by the end of this year
is the concept of establishing
state-specific average emission rates
within the power sector to serve as the
baseline and budgets for future Control
regimes now let me say that again within
each state that states power plants or
power sector the average emission rates
taking into account historic fuel use
and higher emission levels from Barry
Cole heavy states like West Virginia and
Ohio the average emission rate serving
is the baseline probably over a
multi-year period for the construction
of an emissions budget that would then
have to come down in time in order to
meet the performance standards the
performance objectives of section 111 d
that's just going to serve as my teaser
because we're not prepared to fully
flesh that out yet the the tools for
achieving those reductions of course are
you know multiple and varied as many
ways as there are to reduce energy usage
to reduce pollution to become more
efficient there's there's all kinds of
techniques but as I say at EPA has not
been willing to even announce the
willingness to
to to meet those that section of the
statute to regulate existing plants so
for now it's um it's a conversation
that's largely happening outside of EPA
so as you can probably tell the direct
regulation of carbon under the Clean Air
Act has not been a popular idea in
Washington with conservative politicians
and the Republican Party they have tried
to strip that authority they have voted
on multiple bills in the house that have
successfully eliminated that authority
under the Clean Air Act and those bills
have died and gone nowhere in the Senate
the election is going to be very
important to determine whether there's a
change in administration and a change in
policy where there's a change in the
Senate and a change in opposition to
some truly ghastly bills that the house
it's passed in the 112th Congress and
the final adoption of new source
performance standards for the power
sector will probably face a vote in
Congress under a law called the
Congressional review Act which is
essentially a congressional veto law
that survives constitutional trouble
under I NS versus chata because of the
way it's been structured and is the bane
of my existence because I fight
defensive battles fending off attacks on
clean air rules under this statute all
the time but we haven't lost yet and
we're not planning on losing any vote
under the Congressional review Act when
these new standards come up for a review
by Congress as they invariably will
since that's the way the law works let
me dive into my second category I want
to leave time for some discussion this
is the accomplishment of co2 reductions
as co-benefits or collateral benefits of
reducing conventional air pollution
under the Clean Air Act this is where
most of the activity of EPA's air office
actually occurs working on rules to
reduce smog and soot pollution
interstate pollution which blows into
New England and where we are right now
from the Ohio River Valley power plants
that rule is called the cross-state air
pollution rule
it's manifestation issued by the the
Obama administration an earlier version
by the Bush administration was called
the Queen air interstate rule both of
them were unceremoniously overturned by
the DC Circuit Court of Appeals the
Obama version most recently in a ruling
about a month ago in a dreadfully
horrifying decision by Brett Kavanaugh
and judge judge Griffin with a vigorous
to my mind overwhelmingly persuasive
dissent by Judge Rogers on the DC
Circuit a terrific judge by the way if
any of you ever had the chance to clerk
for her she's um she's an extraordinary
jurist the the decision is on appeal the
Obama administration appealed it last
week we followed suit since we had
intervened on EPA side and it you know
there it would achieve a significant at
least a meaningful reduction in co2
emissions by virtue of the decisions
made by the power sector whether to
comply with that rule by retrofitting
with pollution controls retiring and
shutting down all together or repowering
to natural gas that's the the the
Trinity of my life retirement retrofits
or repowering okay those are that that
is the conversation in Washington
surrounding the pilot the power sector
and this interstate pollution rule and a
second rule are the drivers for that
conversation that second rule is the
mercury and air toxic standards I have
been working on for over ten years of my
life and we helped overturn a really
awful mercury trading rule adopted by
the Bush administration in 2005 I hope
to overturn that rule in 2008 the Obama
administration abandoned the Bush
administration's appeal to the Supreme
Court shortly after taking office and
then in December of 2011 issued these
groundbreaking mercury near talk
standards which far and away on the
regulatory front have been the biggest
driver over this Trinity of decisions
retirement repowering or retrofits now I
say on the regulatory front the most
powerful force on the regulatory front
what has been the single most powerful
force overall and determining which of
those decisions are made price of
natural gas market conditions
surrounding the economic viability of
coal plants especially coal plants that
are 50 60 70 years old operate anywhere
from two to ten percent of the year some
of them more but marginal plants plants
that by all rights factoring in their
costs and their externalities probably
should be retired and those are the
decisions that these business owners are
making overwhelmingly on the basis of
economics now I'm creating this kind of
dissonance here between the regulatory
drivers and the and the economic drivers
because that dismiss and that tension
has become the crux of the political
fight in Washington the war on coal who
has heard that phrase in the current
political campaign okay that is that's a
slogan the that has been seized upon by
the president's political opponents to
describe this entire dynamic and the
regulatory work of the Environmental
Protection Agency and the energy
policies of the administration a report
just came out a couple of days ago that
I come into your attention if you're
interested in this subject by the
brattle group and cambridge it's a group
of consultants for for industry paying
clients and what they they estimated
that let's see I wrote this down in 2010
they had estimated that by July of 2012
approximately 30 gigawatts of coal plant
capacity had announced retirement by
2016 okay 30 gigawatts of coal capacity
is about ten percent of total coal
capacity okay that was two years ago now
in the report just issued last week they
announced that
we find at 59 277 gigawatts of coal
plant capacity are likely to retire
instead of retrofit with environmental
equipment these retirement sakr absent
any future regulations restricting
carbon emissions generally these results
are about 25 gigawatts higher than the
retirement levels we projected in 2010
due mainly to lower expected gas prices
despite the somewhat more lenient
environmental regulations we currently
envision now what's that last phrase
mean in 2010 industry with predicting
that the sky was going to fall because
these regulations hadn't come out yet
when they did come out they were
actually more lenient than industry had
been kind of you know predicting or you
know banging the gong about up on the
hill so this this is an extremely
important point to take away the dynamic
surrounding natural gas on the
retirement and retrofit decisions of the
coal sector how much we meet our public
health objectives for reducing smog suit
and toxic pollution the time frames by
which we do so and then by extension the
progress that we can make in reducing
carbon pollution is is an extraordinary
factor fracking I hear people thinking
fracking I hear people thinking that
natural gas is hardly carbon free all
true all true and that's just part of
the the complicated dynamic and mix that
informs this entire conversation I'm
going to just jump quickly through this
last category the third category other
because it's it's it's less a focus
right now there was the Connecticut
versus EPA decision in the Supreme Court
and eight to nothing decision in which
common law and nuisance cases brought by
a bunch of states and public land trust
groups represented by NRDC and others
was summarily rejected by Supreme Court
Sotomayor was not sitting because she
had been on the panel and the Second
Circuit Court that the Supreme Court
reversed
it summarily rejected the use of common
law nuisance as a tool for combating
carbon pollution through the courts what
it did however in this decision
post-dated Massachusetts versus EPA what
it did was reaffirm the availability of
the Clean Air Act to serve as a source
of authority for reducing carbon
pollution so you had even the
conservative justices who were in the
dissent in the 5-4 decision
Massachusetts versus EPA agreeing based
upon that precedent although Alito in
Thomas wrote a snide little concurrence
that they said well if we have to accept
Massachusetts versus GPA is law then I
suppose we have to do this too so that
you know that is kind of that's cut off
that that channel as as an advocacy tool
by and large states laboratories
democracy blah blah blah there's you
know a lot of activities that are
occurring in the states chiefly and you
know where more than California
certainly other say it's the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative in New England
and the Northeast Reggie is a kind of
interstate compact for reducing carbon
pollution through a you know kind of
modest rating mechanism that activity is
continuing and again based upon
political swings if a political party
electrolytic a political party hostile
to carbon regulation happens to be
elected in the fall you'll probably
swing back to more activities taking
place in the states so I'm going to stop
there because that was a much longer
overview in summary then I'd perhaps
intended but hopefully it provided a lot
of you know grist and fodder for
conversation really about any one of the
elements that people want to discuss and
we can have a we can have a conversation
any any takers questions yes sir about
fracking
it doesn't seem to be any or very little
information being imparted about the
problems ancillary problems of fracking
for example the use of water and perhaps
is some pollution methane or whatever
pollution I'm Janice but especially the
water issue and I'm just wondering as a
professional the field why haven't we
heard more about that assuming that is a
problem which I i think it is especially
the Midwest with the lowering aquifers
what basically what's yours what's your
take on that um well coming from
Washington I always like to follow the
advice of Watergate and follow the money
but there's an extraordinary amount of
money being made on fracking and you
know that dynamic in my opinion I don't
know if this is a nerd you see the
institutional position but in my opinion
it's driving the dynamics surrounding
kind of a local political reaction state
reaction the congressional reaction even
EPA in many respects under the Obama
administration you have a lot of you
know kind of grassroots anger over lands
being taken and groundwater being
contaminated smells water may be
catching on fire maybe not catching on
the fire and the the the reactions of
the you know the local governments and
the environmental agencies at the local
level and even at the federal level have
not been robust and the legal and
regulatory authorities have not been
created in many respects and there are
political fights occurring now over the
very creation of those or even the study
leading to the very creation of those
andrew Cuomo i mean there's all kinds of
you know local political fights
pennsylvania i mean texas in some
respects it's almost you know it's
almost analogous to kind of be able to
the alaska oil boom where you know
that they write to get checks every year
from you know the oil deposits
underneath the state and a lot of local
communities and politicians see this is
a check writing exercise for the tax
base and many other forms of you cannot
mukhda velopment in those areas there is
a great deal of advocacy that is
occurring by the national environmental
groups and the local environmental
groups but I don't fundamentally
disagree with your assessment of the
effectiveness to date because of the
sheer opposition by the companies and a
fairly unified but fashion field road we
will have eggs a serious environmental
problem or what a problem because of all
this hi my view is that the problem is
is you know so unaddressed and so
prevalent that you will have a
regulatory and legal fabric in place far
before then not as fast as we would like
but one that you know the disclosure and
transparency is the first battle that in
many respects isn't the real battle
they're going to have to crumble on that
it's just not a sustainable position
that we can refuse to tell you you know
which poisons we're putting into your
ground water but you know the real
battle is going to be on the control
measures and and in the traditional
pollution you know externalities that
are the real drive you know for the
anger in the frustration so I don't work
on those issues in sufficient depth to
you know provide you an array of
examples of what is happening and where
the next battles and pressure points are
likely going to be but I know it is it
is a topic of a lot of of activity and
increased resources ranging from you
know kind of grassroots litigation you
know with and on behalf of
municipalities and people whose lands
are being taken and but you know it's
it's it's an interesting exciting area
of law and the sense that we're kind of
at the very
beginning and I can't predict with any
you know reliable accuracy where it's
going to go can you discuss the NRDC's
choice to work with you Obama
administration get clean air act as a
tool to regulate carbon pollution
instead of the choice to use location we
do both I'm suing the Obama
administration in numerous cases right
now my friend Kate will tell you that
well actually Bruce kind of gently
touched upon it which is I tend to be
fairly aggressive and you know we we we
go where the answers take us and if you
have allies that are working on rules
furthering your goals it makes sense to
work with them and to be supportive
where they deserve to be supported but
i'll submit 200-page comments that have
tons of you know critical comments and
things that they should change but at
the end of the day if they issue a rule
that's sufficiently strong and worthy of
support will support it the mercury and
air toxic standards that i mentioned
right now we are intervening on the
obama administration's behalf to defend
those rules the Sierra Club is
intervening on the Obama
administration's have to defend those
rules but they've also filed a lawsuit
against the rules I made the decision on
our behalf that it was a little that you
know prevented some tensions and
challenges that I I chose to avoid but
that's not that's not unheard of you
know what you know Washington is a funny
place and you can work with an
administration one day and be meeting
with the head of a program with the
knowledge that you've sued them five
times and it's just it's just business
and I was like what is that some line
from a mafia movie probably just
business but and I said it's completely
usual it's there's nothing out of the
ordinary about that please so relative
to existing industrial sources of co2
under I think you said earlier that you
it was your choice to not be sue them as
you did bush administration now we we we
sued the Bush administration which meant
that this EPA inherited that lawsuit we
entered into a settlement agreement with
this administration which the prior
administration wouldn't even entertain
and the settlement agreement has
essentially been breached and then the
decision comes well what do you do about
it you know do you go back to court for
a multi-year process or you know do you
wait for something in the political
climate to change you know there's a lot
of a lot of factors I'm not going to go
into because they are pending
discussions but you know that too is is
nothing unusual for an administrative
lawyer in Washington to to make that
kind of calculation yes can you foresee
any strip scenario that would make
climate but where you could imagine
climate legislation passing and so maybe
becoming less sort of nastily partisan
and and then how do you think that this
business strategy of looking of looking
more at regulations and using the
existing regulations sort of how that
might shape that possibility the answer
is yes I do I'm an optimist I wouldn't
be an environmental attorney if I
weren't so I think that that will change
it's going to it's going to take time
and you know just despite the the
absolutely correct assessment that the
political system in Washington seems
entirely unresponsive to the opinions or
wishes of the American people those
public opinion polls in public sentiment
you know that does matter we you know
with with kind of the rise of the Tea
Party and the Republican take over their
house in 2010 the the public support for
men the theory of manmade climate change
plummeted theory i'm going to have to
put a dollar in the cup it back it in
our you see so but if you look at the
polls today i mean i think i saw one
recently just today or yesterday it was
sixty sixty-five percent belief in
man-made climate change like eighty-six
percent among Democrats sixty-three
percent of my independence and like
thirty percent or Republicans or
something it was pretty dreadful and out
front you know that I I think that
you're going to have to see continuing
improvement on that score so we put a
lot of effort into those communications
and education and working with
scientists and that's going to influence
the dynamic but you know this is a topic
for i dono Yale's political science
program but the the the climate in
Washington is so nasty in partisan worse
than anything i've ever seen and I lived
I mean I you know kind of was groomed
through the Gingrich Congress and that
was about as bad as I think we had seen
by then at least in the modern
environmental era this is vastly worse
it's much much worse and so I think
something's going to have to happen with
that political party where the Tea Party
wing and I'm just using that a shorthand
you know receives kind of a comeuppance
of sorts from the adults in the party
and that you're going to have to have
kind of a takeover of that in order for
that progress to be accelerated because
right now we're on a very slow train for
progress which I think will happen but
it's going to be slow particular
backlash because because of using the
Clean Air Act or using the courts this
sort of post post cap and trade strategy
that you were talking about I mean that
that's a lot of what what makes that
sort of war on coal it makes them so
angry is that you know you're not going
through this legislative process you're
going through this kind of backdoor we
do you think that that could could
entrench it more'n in this as a sort of
left left that then makes it you know
makes it more difficult to get sort of
legislation of the future do you think
it's not
hi I'm not seeing the backlash among the
broader public and I don't know if I
would call it a even a backlash among
the Republicans because I don't think
there was ever up I don't know they were
was always lash I mean it's just they
just they just seem to believe that in
their DNA I don't think it's backdoor
regulation where you have the Supreme
Court upholding the authority and EPA is
carrying it out based upon the science
that was hundreds and hundreds of pages
long in the endangerment finding
rulemaking okay so you know I have to
just kind of disagree with you on that
notion but sure it's easier for
politicians to cast it that way but I'm
not seeing that line of attack
resonating I'm not seeing the war on
coal driving the national campaign I'm
not going to talk about the campaign but
no I'm not you know I'm always on guard
for that but that's my job but I'm not
not seeing that yes sir you mentioned
briefly some possible changes that I
happen if a certain party that is
possible to climate change regulation
were to win the election but do you see
any changes if they don't win and the
current administration season Howard if
they've changed course after the
election or so continuous way you
described well I don't know I mean in
all honesty we will continue our
advocacy either way and the beauty of a
law like the Clean Air Act it is both
wonderfully aspirational and
prescriptive more so than any other
environmental statute it's almost as
defining features in some ways the
combination of the aspiration on the
prescriptive we have the legal
authorities in order to bring about that
change regardless of who's in the White
House now obviously the pace changes the
the need to go back to court perhaps
changes but we will you know we will
continue ahead you know expecting based
upon statements and records one person
to do one thing and one person to do
another we're obviously pressing ahead
with the regular for the regulation of
existing sources because we hold out
hope that the administration will change
its mind we're not being given
particular signs of that now but again
we have to be optimistic work and your
question is is far more you know
sophisticated than that because of
course an election in the cauldron of
you know political ferment and torment
that we operate in that again i cannot
stress how integral it is to everything
that happens the advocacy on the hill
and in the courts and in the executive
branch it's absolutely fundamental and
so there's this almost kind of a surreal
cognitive dissonance to our existence
where okay well something's going to
happen on the first week in november is
going to completely change and dictate
the course of my life for the next
foreseeable years and have to roll with
it and that happens all the time there
will be staffers who lose their jobs
based upon what happens you know what
that's just that's Washington's the wait
the way it happens yes sir soon your
options here this gives viewers a code
that a bit of communication illusions
seem like the benefits that you
were mainly cold retirements I heard
that correctly from and then you could
also look at well the Beast an excuse to
our standards as sort of preventing
future coal plants you could look at on
these standards as again possibly
creating more retirements than utility
MACT all of these rules but it reading
toward retirement and yet it seems like
the environmental community as a whole
is doing everything that it can to say
no no no we're not trying to make coal
retirements happen we're just trying to
help them clean up there after whatever
it is so I guess being the theme is sort
of talking about climate change without
talking about climate change maybe what
about talking about coal retirements
without talking about covert elements
like why is there a need to take the
conversation on the opponent's terms and
say you're totally right to be concerned
about Torico retirement and luckily
we're not doing that when from an
outsider's perspective it would be very
hard to come to an independent
conclusion that that's not that wouldn't
be a positive outcome in the mind
well that that's I mean very well stated
with a lot of embedded insights and it
reveals in some respects a distensible
surface division between some
environmental organizations the Sierra
Club has a campaign in which they were
affirmatively running against the
continuing existence of goal planes we
do not you know subscribe in those stark
terms and yet the shared objectives of
both of our organizations is to enforce
the laws and those laws bring about
certain overwhelming public health
benefits that outweigh cost by factors
of 10 and 30 to 1 and yet you're
enforcing the laws that Congress and the
president and earlier president
instructed the agency to enforce now the
the consequences of that law enforcement
and the decisions made by companies will
certainly lead to retirement natural gas
repowering is something that I think has
to be factored in as well that i'll
accept kind of the duality of your of
your question you know if that's how
opponents want to characterize the work
that I do in enforcing the law again as
the director of kind of the conventional
clean air program that's fine I've been
accused of worse things on television so
it is it is not the driving motivation
behind our advocacy I think the Sierra
Club might answer that question a little
bit differently and of course the
backdrop to your question is the
communities that depend upon coal the
workers that depend upon coal there are
a lot of human factors and political
factors that enter into this that I
don't take lightly and that we don't
take lightly but as long as we are
pursuing public health objectives are
overwhelmingly more favorable for the
public and doing so by actually
enforcing the law sleep very well at
night
except for the damn puppy yeah coming at
it from the same angle which is that hi
I see the benefits bigger than the
detriments but it seems like in the
political fondant aside from the Sierra
Club there's an unwillingness to just
say to walk into Inhofe's office and say
you're right that's what we're doing
like coal plants will close because of
these standards but that's not a bad day
instead there seems to be something that
says no no it's not the standards its
natural gas prices we're not doing it
it's going to happen anyway I just what
is there to do it's an awesome which is
blocking his office and say you're right
I love to invite you to accompany me on
that trip sometime the I mean that the
truth is that the second factor is the
factually correct explanation for the
decisions and if it's so happens to be
consistent with you know kind of the
objectives of my advocacy and the
political you know kind of acceptability
of that advocacy then so be it but I
would just submit to you as a as an
advocate that's not the strategy it
would adopt and I say that not in order
to suggest that there's some obfuscation
going on on our part because I I'm
serious when I tell you that the
objective of delivering these public
health benefits by enforcing the law is
the driver and if there are those
collateral consequences even what some
would characterize as classical
collateral benefits there are collateral
you know disadvantages that's you know
that's the consequence of living in a
rule of law
yes progress and kind of change
legislation a lot of vulnerable
communities are resorting to the courts
to try and get help with assistance and
I'm thinking primarily at the village of
key bonita and I don't know how well
aware you are of the lawsuit but I had
egg is like to question my general
question is what do you think of the use
of time and change litigation whether
successful or not as a way to kind of
destabilize the status quo and try and
push action on the policy level and then
I don't know if you've any thoughts on
the lawsuit and of the Ninth Circuit
just recently dismissed it so yeah I
mean I think it's a tough it's a tough
lawsuit to win in the courts with the
precedent and the Ninth Circuit which
should or could be the most sympathetic
Circuit Court out there if you read that
opinion you get a pretty good sense that
it's probably not going to prevail we
have not joined those lawsuits you know
NRDC brings lawsuits based upon our
assessment of the viability of the case
and and that includes pushing the law we
don't bring lawsuits to make political
statements or to engender greater public
awareness of the issue that's just
that's our own view it's not it's not
it's not the right use of the courts in
our view ID I don't know whether we were
ever asked or invited to participate in
that case but based upon some earlier
cases that didn't appear to be any more
promising it was probably you know an
assessment of the potential viability of
the case that kept the kept some groups
off the cases that might have otherwise
been involved you know I hope I've shown
though by discussing kind of this all of
the above strategy that if there were
viable courses in the courts we'd be the
first to you know analyze and pursue
them and we started this
you know thinking about these common law
nuisance cases probably six to eight
years ago and hired an attorney to who
is dedicated to doing that research for
a couple of years where the cases were
brought so you know you push the
envelope but some envelopes aren't ready
to be pushed and unfortunately I think
those those those groups ran squarely
into that so yes sir are the new
standard is good enough for now is the
more they need to be done either on the
fuel side or reducing driving side oh
gosh reducing driving side for sure the
their dual standards or fuel economy
standards issued by the department
transportation there are actually added
bit additive benefits provided by the
carbon pollution standards issued by EPA
and so we thought we think and thought
that those were you know independently
important measures to promote built into
the structure of those dual integrated
rules is an expectation of kind of
another another level of achievement in
the out-years I'm not sure exactly what
year I don't work on that primarily but
there was an expectation of you know
deeper emissions cuts and we believe
that you know the Clean Air Act is a
viable and available tool to do that in
many respects though without also
getting a handle Don VMT or vehicle
miles traveled you're going to have a
terrible time truly you know
internalizing the co2 pollution or smog
or soot pollution from the vehicle
sector and I work on the VMT side more
with respect to ozone pollution and and
urban traffic but your point is very
well taken that you really need to
tackle both and you know barring some
disastrous intervention by politicians
to strip that authority
I think you'll you'll continue to see
progress now the key difference there
versus the power sector is the agreement
by the automaker's with the standards
and when that happens in my world that's
you know that's another achievement
marked because then the political
opposition kind of you know dwindles to
the auto dealers they brought suit
against that those standards they didn't
have a prayer in court and they lost but
having the automaker's on the
administration side politically made all
the difference in the world relative to
the to the power sector where the
opposite is true yes sir just a sort of
question on the state average tuition
rates that were involved under dash just
because I think I didn't get the notion
about how much reduction should be in
your paper to say something that is
going to prepare and this regard you
have any view that of you lots babe
American impression of Washington Navy
inner circle that you are untouchable
and or China they say China is building
one powers and say coal power station
and week one nuclear power station a
month was it's in the US perspective in
terms of China being able to set
stricter levels terms of emissions
compared to you us and even European
Union so let's say do you have any set
lever on this kind of argument in terms
of convincing even US politicians to to
see what other countries and in terms of
look guys and even did the beasts the
China the Chinese are doing much better
what is busily impression that the US
political elite has about a stop um car
should be like a treatise but the the
reaction of the you know political
opponent class in Washington has been to
use the lever and
beat us over the head with it like a
tire iron that you know we're not going
to do anything until China does
something first I mean it's like seventh
grade or something and it's completely
juvenile but that that's been the
political reaction now I did not mention
the reduction that we are modeling on
purpose because we're not we're not
discussing those quite yet but it's not
going to be enough it's going to be
insufficient to address the scale of the
problem here or globally but you know we
have like like you know Beckett said you
have to go on you have to you have to
make progress with the the tools and in
the times that you live in and the you
know the ability to demonstrate a
commitment and you know a politically
acceptable solution advancing technology
potentially transforming the way a
sector operates that then can be
exported as examples around the world
we've done this with LED and gasoline I
mean NRDC helped secure that achievement
in the mid to late 70s and now they're
around the world you have led in far
less gasoline than you're used to still
in some countries and I don't know if
that's going to be enough time I don't
know if we're going to make progress on
the pace that we're set now and enough
time to make a difference or to make any
difference but you have to you have to
you know have to keep on keeping on and
the you know the topic of China is a
whole nother lecture series and we've
established an office there we have 30
35 people there we we make what progress
we can you know they have they have the
greatest laws in the world on paper it's
just they're not enforced you know
there's power plants they they're
supposed to have great controls for
sulfur and smog and so it they don't
turn them on I'm over generalizing here
but a huge enforcement problem huge and
implementation problems with the Chinese
environmental system and that's on the
conventional pollution side yeah in
summer spa
they are ahead of us on some you know
energy efficiency building codes and
things I don't know how much they're
followed her enforce but it's one of the
advantages of a centralized government
the ability to enforce that kind of
mandate and they've taken a lot of their
lessons from California I meet with
study groups from you cap from China
probably once a month sometimes twice a
month judges environmental officials
even activists they you know they're
kind of voracious for those lessons to
follow but the scale of the problem is
just so daunting so yes sir in the next
four years given all the issues that are
under your purview climate changes and
you can do in the environment where do
you see I'm asking you to put on your
your prognosticator hat where do you see
the most progress being made as far as
your concern in Washington on what
issues most breakthroughs whatever you
want to consider next four years well I
I hope that we will you know complete
the successful cleanup and
transformation of the power sector
coal-fired power plants but also oil and
natural gas in a way that you know
brings them into the 20th first century
20 years after they should have been a
part of the 20th century that that has
been kind of the abiding problem of you
know the nations environmental profile
for the past 40 years or longer in many
respects and you know I don't want that
answer to be a cop out because it's not
the identification of the next new or
sexy issue but that issue is so
fundamental to the the problems of a ver
pollution mountaintop removal you know
water pollution and I guess I include
fracking within that ambit because the
fuel sources are have always been as
much a part of the problem as the
combustion issue and we try to address
them holistically
um that I you know and that that in part
reflects my bias would spend the focus
of my career for 20 years but I still
think it's the case over the next four
years now if you ask me 10 or 15 years
that might not be the answer but I'd
probably have to give that more thought
I mean certainly climate change would be
the abiding problem and hopefully the
source of solutions so I'll eat if that
is we have but thank you John for you
too